we showed you earlier how millions of
people in southern california face new
water restrictions because of a record
drought that's crippling the southwest
across the border in southern nevada
they've been conserving water for years
now people are taking it a step further
ripping out all the grass that soaks up
the water in the middle of the desert
then tracy shows us how las vegas that's
right las vegas has become an unlikely
model for water conservation without
giving up any of its city's glamour
of all the words that come to mind when
you think of las vegas restraint is
probably not one of them for having a
reputation as a city of excess we're
actually one of the most water efficient
cities in the world
john ensminger is general manager of the
southern nevada water authority this is
a pump station he showed us one of las
vegas 54 pump stations they deliver
water from nearby lake mead on the
colorado river the nation's largest
reservoir everything we use indoors is
recycled if it hits a drain in las vegas
we clean it we put it back into lake
mead so all those showers sinks and
toilets and all those hotel rooms that
all gets cleaned and put back in the
lake you can literally leave every
faucet every shower running and it won't
consume any more water
in the past two decades lake mead has
dropped a startling 180 feet due to a
devastating mega drought made worse by
climate change and the rapid growth of
cities and agriculture in the southwest
but southern nevada beat the odds adding
750 000 people since 2002 while cutting
its overall water use by 26 percent
in part by spending millions to get
homeowners to install desert landscaping
and mandating precisely when and how
much anything outdoors can be watered
now it's doubling down to save every
last drop
a new law a first of its kind in the
nation bans what's known as
non-functional grass the kind of stuff
that looks good along roadways and
roundabouts but serves no actual purpose
it's being torn out all over town
sweetheart surprising some like gail
greenstein i am going to miss it because
i mean there's nothing better than
smelling fresh cut grass in the morning
rolling up the green carpet does make a
difference watering one square foot of
grass in las vegas uses 73 gallons of
water per year
drought tolerant landscaping uses just
18 gallons the water authority says
banning non-functional grass will save
nearly 10 billion gallons of water 10
percent of southern nevada's total water
supply this grass is considered
decorative it's considered
non-functional cameron donnarumma is one
of the city's 14 water waste
investigators sworn to protect
and conserve there is some contributing
flow he's on the lookout for those
committing the cardinal sin of sin city
letting water run down the drain
fines start at eighty dollars and top
out at nearly thirteen hundred water
cannot leave the property so as you can
kind of see water is definitely leaving
and going down the street so this is
considered a waterways violation
but what about the city's most iconic
water feature
oh there we go
that's pretty cool
you got a very nice water feature here
at your hotel yes we do
world renown
anthony williams is a senior vice
president with mgm resorts which owns
the bellagio hotel and its famed
fountains out front
he took us for a ride on the lake for an
up close look at this wall of water
this seems awfully wasteful you're
saying you're not really wasting much
water here we're not
he says all the water here comes from a
private well not the colorado river and
the water that evaporates into the hot
desert air this is very cool to see this
up close
he is replaced with recycled water from
this 1.5 million gallon
[Music]
the
pool
of the cirque du soleil show oh
overall mgm says it has cut its water
use at its various vegas properties by
30 percent in the past three years the
reality is we all have to use less water
john enzminger says as climate change
makes the west hotter and drier
cities can learn from las vegas and
commit to conservation the situation
we're facing
i believe isn't drought it's the long
term or ratification of the desert
southwest so these plans need to be
permanent
and they need to build upon themselves
each and every year because the one
thing this city in the desert can't
afford to gamble on
is its water supply
for cbs mornings i'm ben tracy in las
vegas
so they're recycling the water in the
fountain and that also includes the
30-minute hangover shower how did you
hang out at that bachelor party you know
we've all been there tony you've been
there tony no i've read some articles
about it
they told me some stories
that said sorry what happens in vegas
stays in vegas unless you're talking
about how to save water there you go
that water fountain is very very cool it
really is